uh and one day the party runs out
just to add to your point
um i i learned this quite a few years
ago that a greatest achievement someone
could ever have is to see their
grandchildren
so when people talk about their parent
like you having kids and how is it going
to affect your kids it's like
the byproduct of you having kids will be
your grandkids and that's when you'll
see the and reap the rewards of
everything you'll see everything come
full
[Music]
you'll see everything come
you'll see everything come full circle
and it's more so that you need to have
kids in order to have grandkids and if
you leave it too late you'll be in a
position where you'll be 60 and you may
see other family members with grandkids
but you have nothing to show
for your life through
your lines they will
like come out with that travel picture
or whatever you know
but nobody's going to look at it because
no one's going to care yeah i don't care
he said i probably wouldn't care about
your grandchildren or whatever do you do
you think that a life that's only about
you is worth living where it's just me
me me selfish all the time it's
everything's about me and my feelings
but if you if you if you're alone
forever that's that's what life's about
it's you like to me life's about people
and if i don't if i don't have a family
to share it with like oh yeah no but
they're they'll die
i don't i don't no i have a sister i
have brothers i've
there's no one that will be at your
funeral talking about how hard you
worked in your great career yeah okay
and like honestly like my channel is
pretty big like by and large most people
would say i'm very successful at my age
it means nothing if i don't get married
like every point of view
no i mean it's not a different like
like i think a girl get married or
nothing you don't have children and if i
don't get married like honestly a girl
that can't get married is a loser
so just like just like that just like
yeah just like just like marry cutie
could you lose her loser i mean look at
lolo
because we still studying where she's
covered
but you have grandchildren and you have
that the memories that you were talking
about you still have that no but you
want to be okay so i raised my kids at
every statistical disadvantage that's
selfish on me no but listen selfish i
mean you have children they're grown and
they've had grandchildren and then now
you're divorcing for whatever reason
have you not still had that life that
you've been talking about you still have
the grandchildren you still have it
there you still have that full circle
okay i would say i grew up in a family i
have nine siblings i have two parents
i've been married for like 30 years
it is not the same when there's two
christmases
it's not the same like the
i i talked to people from like split
family homes and tell them about like
the traditions that me and my family
have like we go as adults take pictures
with santa every year we all go to the
fourth of july the whole family comes
like we do these events all year it's
actually stressful because my mom
expects us to be at so much [ __ ] but you
don't get that in a single parent home
and when i talk to people from
single-parent homes they're jealous
like they wish they had that and it's
like why would i put my kids at every
statistical disadvantage because it's
not about me anymore once i have
children who [ __ ] my happiness no but
the children
the point i made is the children are
grown up now they're not kids like
you've had your marriage you they lived
in a two-parent household they've grown
up they've gone to college uni wherever
they're older they've had children you
have grandchildren but now the only the
only difference is you weren't married
yeah that's that's what i'm trying to
say oh am i still with the husband i
just get divorced later like you weren't
married but you had children oh i i'm
okay with like like i committed yeah
like i i know the laws are kind of [ __ ]
for men so if if it was something
similar but you don't get the government
involved fine
but so then
no i would say you still need a ring
it's just like there's people that do it
outside of the government like that you
know they do it in their church or
whatever so you need the ring for that
whole grandchildren
i mean yeah you should you should be
married before you have kids whether
it's with the government or not so
you're saying you should is it because
of god or because of government because
that it
that gives the kids the best outcomes
that you've got married yes but you can
still be in a household where you're
together and not married and the
children have both mom and dad in the
house it's possible they have a happy
home it's possible but not probable okay
they have a happy home and then you have
grandchildren and all that stuff
is that that's still the goal no that's
still happiness no the gospel
yeah the girls i mean rings i mean you
had the chip
but he doesn't he doesn't want to marry
you no no no no no no you just said the
goal was having grandchildren and having
your future and your loins and all that
sort of stuff which you can still have
without a ring that's what i'm trying to
say so you can have all of those things
without a ring my point was that is one
thing
one aspect that not having kids or
looking to have kids with the person you
want to find
that you come across in your later ages
as a woman
your goal is the ring
that's that from what i've learned is it
the ring or is it the children it's
commitment oh it's both the ring it's
the legacy it's the man that you respect
it's the man that you look up to and
you've got him and you've got him to
commit so you got him to commit but you
didn't have kids
what i don't even know what these
hypothetical situations you guys have
been through
okay this is this is the goal i want to
get married and then have kids i don't
if it's outside of the government fine
but i still want to be married and some
level so you want marriage first and
then children yeah i think i think it's
quite selfish to do the other first and
a lot of girls trap guys in order to do
it
yeah and like i think it's it's selfish
because you're thinking of yourself
before the kids
put the kids first so no matter what age
you're at you're you're waiting for the
ring before the kids
yeah i mean oh are you sorry i'm 25. 25.
so then if you meet the guy this are you
dating married now engaged like what's
your i don't have a boyfriend no so then
if you met someone and then you're
dating it's going well but then he
doesn't propose until
i don't know you're 28 29
and then you don't have kids until your
eggs are like you said after 30 your
eggs are now like would is is that
is that that's you're okay with that
then after two years cut it off yeah i'd
say yeah two years cut it off
earlier
no no no i'm telling you if you're
dating so if you're dating someone for
more than two years yeah where's the
commitment why hasn't he done it no he's
proposed but you're not you're not
married yet
you can have a ring but you can go you
can get married in a way go to a
courthouse i don't need a wedding so
you're happy 25 and then he proposes the
27 you get married the next day
yeah i mean honestly i'm uh i'm like
i've never cared about a wedding because
i don't think it's about the wedding
it's about a marriage yeah yeah so who
who care like i mean if i got married i
could go do it at a courthouse just make
sure my parents and my siblings could
come so then if he doesn't propose after
27
are you you're back out there looking
for someone else mm-hmm yeah who
probably you're getting
yeah then i'll be on discount yeah be on
sale so you just pick whoever will take
you
i'd pick the best bet i could that's
that's like
that's the saying like pick the best bit
yeah the one that ticks some of your
boxes you won't just pick anyone because
i'm 27 i need to just quickly get
married because like that's actually
yeah
yeah
go for someone that
you're only as valuable as your options
i remember i remember a girl saying to
me yeah i remember a girl saying to me
that
there were a certain
type of man that
constantly moved to her
so she had to look at it and say well
if these are the type of guys that move
to me
then
i need to readjust and find a way to see
what these guys are about
so if you're a girl and you go out and
every single man that moves